[Music]
my name is Bill ringland I'm a
operational member of agrain agre grain
is a family run business that's been in
operation for over 30 years now uh we're
based in Narine but have recently uh
opened a receival site in Canal a few
things it's obviously a huge drawing
area for for grain in New South Wales a
huge opportunity for us to take the next
step as a business and also service an
area that had been crying out for
someone else to step into the to the
area another strong advantage to the
area and us being here is the diversity
in the soil soil types um you know from
walgate through to gagen Bone there's
some um you know varying ranges of uh
soil typee Black soil typee red soil
type which um obviously accommodate
different crop types so that gives us a
um commodity diversity I suppose which
is important for us as a business we've
just had uh Western Australian based
company take a major shareholding in our
business so Plum grve coming into uh a
shareholding in agrain means that we
have uh an additional Capital EXP
expenditure to be able to spend on
facilities like the one in canul um to
try and service the grow a bit better
the train that's coming today uh it's
heading to Port botney from there it'll
go to multiple destinations all around
the world a lot into southeast Asia uh
China and some chickpeas into India
we're heading into our third Harvest
since being in canul and um a big
positive for us is the way that the
local Growers have embraced uh us being
here um we're here for the long term and
look to become a part of the
community from a tonage point of view
historically the canul and wget area
been upwards of 3 or 400,000 tons of
wheight um and on top of that there's
there's obviously chickpeas and barley
and canola as well depending on what
rotations people are running so it's um
it's a huge opportunity and a huge
capture area for us
it's potentially a almost a $20 a ton
Freight Advantage having someone like us
here for them um as a especially with
the pulses instead of going to somewhere
like narab or dbo they've got the option
to come here and we're essentially a a
step forward in their supply chain which
is a huge Advantage for them I think in
essence we're a storage and Export
facility so during Harvest a grower has
the opportunity to either Warehouse
grain with with us uh we can purchase it
off them directly or we'll do contracts
with them for a forward sale our
capacity for storage is around 100,000
tons and with Plum Grove coming on board
we're looking to uh through a number of
stages expand that to hopefully around
200,000 tons in the next 18 or 24 months
[Music]